اذا لمتابعه لاخر المستجدات معنا من غزه
مراسل الجزيره وائل الدحدوح ومعه نتابع
اخر المستجدات وائل
واضح عبد القادر بان الاوضاع في الساعه
الاخيره او اقل من ساعه تقريبا
تراجعت حده الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه على
الاقل في المدى المنظور الذي نشاهده
بالعين المجرده وحتى اصوات الطلعات من
المقاتلات الحربيه لم نعد نستمع اليه بشكل
مكثف كما هو الحال كان على مدار ساعتين
سبقتاه هذه الساعه الاخيره
ولكن بالتاكيد ما تزال اصوات التحليق
المكثف من قبل الطائرات المسيره على
اختلاف انواعها واحجامها ومهامها بطبيعه
الحال تحلق بكثافه في مختلف اجواء محافظات
قطاع غزه يعني كان اخر الغارات تلك التي
استهدفت مناطق عده حقيقه عندما كانت ذروه
هذه الغارات فيما يتعلق على وجه الخصوص
باستهداف المنازل منازل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين في منطقه بلده بيت لاهيا وفي
ايضا في منطقه جباليا وبيت حانون وصولا
الى الزيتون في جنوب مدينه غزه حيث تم
استهداف منزلين وتدميرهما ايضا فضلا عن
ذلك كان هناك تدمير منزل في منطقه دير
البلح وسط قطاع غزه الى جانب هذه
الاستهدافات بالتاكيد كان هناك عدد من
الاستهدافات الاخرى ولكن
بحق عدد من الاراضي الزراعيه كما يعلن جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهذه الاراضي يقول
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بانها تحتوي على
مقدرات للمقاومه الفلسطينيه او ربما اطلقت
منها صواريخ حسب الروايه الاسرائيليه التي
ترد تباعا من مختلف وسائل الاعلام على ايه
حال الاستهدافات مستمره عبد القادر ربما
الان عادت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
الى الاجواء من جديد وكانها ترد على
حديثنا
وبالتالي باتت تحلق هل ستنفذ الان غارات
جديده لانه كلما استمعنا الى اصوات مثل
هذه الاصوات عاده ما تنفذ هذه الطائرات
الحربيه غارات قد تكون نفذت في مناطق
بعيده ليست في منظورنا ومشاهداتنا من قبيل
المناطق الجنوبيه في قطاع غزه مثل خان
يونس ورفح ولكن هذا الحديث يحتاج الى
تاكيد الى تاكيدات وبالتالي خلال الدقائق
القادمه او اللحظات القادمه هل هل
هي طائرات
الزنانه للمراقبه وكذلك تنفيذ العمليات
بالتاكيد يعني هي طائرات حربيه التي عدنا
الى الاستماع اليها الان لكن الطائرات
المسيره على اختلاف انواعها والتي تعرف
هنا في قطاع غزه بالزنانه بالتاكيد هي
اساسا لا تغادر اجواء محافظات قطاع غزه قد
تخف حده هذا التحليق ونوعيات الطائرات
المسيره التي تحلق ولكنها لا تغيب ابدا عن
اجواء محافظات قطاع غزه ولذلك اطلق عليها
من قبل المواطنين الفلسطينيين هنا في قطاع
غزه بالزنانه لانها تصدر صوتا مزعجا جدا
يصدع الرؤوس ويبقي حاله التوتر والتاهب
والقلق في اوساط المواطنين الفلسطينيين
لان هذه الطائرات لم يعد منوطا بها مهمه
واحده او هدف واحد تقوم به او دور واحد
تقوم به وانما بالتاكيد كثير منها يقوم
بعمليات المراقبه لكن ادخل على الخط وفي
في في اطار المهمات بالتاكيد اجيال منها
ما هو انتحاري يحمل شحنات
تفجيريه ويقوم بالمشاركه في عمليات
الاستهداف والاغتيال في الميدان ومنها ما
هو يحمل صواريخ فتاكه لضد الافراد ويقوم
باستهداف المجموعات المتحركه او ربما
الدراجات الناريه التي تتحرك او قد تتحرك
في بعض المناطق اذا عديد من الاجيال
والانواع والاحجام من هذه الطائرات تعج
بها حقيقه اجواء محافظات قطاع غزه الخمس
لكن عندما قلنا ان عدنا الى استماع اصوات
الطائرات هي اصوات حربيه مقاتله لكن في
منظورنا لم نشاهد انها نفذت حتى الان
غارات جديده وبالتالي يبقى الوضع فيما
يتعلق بالغارات الاسرائيليه تلك
السلسله التي انقطعت حتى ما قبل نصف ساعه
من الان او يزيد قليلا وهي التي تركزت
بشكل لافت ضد استهداف المنازل وتدميرها
الامر الذي ادى الى تدمير منازل واحداث
اضرار جسيمه جدا في عدد كبير من المنازل
الاخرى المجاوره للبيوت المستهز